who do you write for do you write for
yourself do you write for your readers
or do you write for your characters
well i create my characters so i'm not
writing for them no i read for myself
i think that's the only way you can
really do it you write the stories that
you want to read
those are the stories that are fun to
write and that you're proud of writing
afterwards
i've known writers who have tried to
write for the readers
um and the readers are such an abstract
term so
you know and essentially they're trying
to write for the market they're looking
what's
being published what's being successful
when they're saying oh look
stories about cats are really popular
i'll write a story about cats of course
by the time they finish it
the cat phases has ended and now
everybody's writing about parakeets
you know you can't kind of chase the
market that way you can't write
in anticipation of oh this is very
hot you know for one thing you don't do
it well you know
you should write the stories that you
want to write the stories that excite
you the stories
that you have a lot of passion and uh
interest in
writing that's the stuff that you'll do
best uh
i know people who are writing you know
like uh zombie book
i hate zombies goddamn zombies but
zombies are popular right now i have to
write about zombies well
they can write a zombie book but i don't
believe they're ever going to write a
good zombie book
you know if you want to write a good
zombie book you need to be like somebody
like max brooks
who like loves zombies i mean i know max
he he gets up in the morning eats
zombies he drinks zombies
zombies are his life you know and he's
going to do the best zombie books of
anybody in the world
and that's that's true no matter what
your genre is or what your passion is
you're right for yourself and hopefully
you find some other people out there who
like what you're doing and then you
have some success so for you it's sci-fi
and fantasy what draws you to those
genres i like the imagination i like the
romance
i like the exotic
feel of a certain kind of science
fiction i mean i
i like science fiction but i like a very
specific kind of science fiction the
the the far future the distant planets
i'm not a big fan of like 10 years in
the future
you know i was never a fan of cyberpunk
i'm a fan of jack vance and
you know earth has spread out to 10 000
planets and
there are all sorts of weird aliens out
there and we're we're encountering who
knows what we're encountering
you know it's uh the the imagination and
the wonder of those worlds the feeling
that anything can happen the
writers who take me to places i've never
been before and show me things i've
never seen before and and
make me think and wonder and and uh
blow my mind as we used to say that's
the kind of stuff i like
so you you uh graduated with a
journalism degree which was kind of what
you did back then when you wanted to be
a creative writer
uh and you went into clark university as
the writer
in residence seems like a pretty sweet
gig
uh but you quit what made you quit to
become a full-time writer
well being a writer writer in residence
was clark college in dubuque iowa
i taught journalism there for two years
and then i wanted to write more so i
said
look i'll be i'll be a writer in
residence instead of teaching four
courses i'll teach one course a semester
i'll continue to advise the school
newspaper and
you know you don't have to pay me so it
wasn't that that big a thing here
but ultimately i decided even that was
taking too much of my time
actually and and seriously there was an
incident that
that occurred uh late in the 70s when i
was teaching college you know i i
published a novel by then
of course i'd published a number of
short stories my head was full of all
the novels and so forth that i
that i wanted to write um
but i figured i had all the time in the
world to to write them
and meanwhile teaching provided me with
a steady
income and a way to pay my mortgage and
put my wife through college and the
other things i was doing at the time
but i had a friend another young writer
he wasn't quite as young as me i was in
my early 30s he was 10 years older he
was
42 years old and
he had started writing later than me but
he was brilliant brilliant writer and he
won the
in 1977 he won the john w campbell award
for the best new writer in the field
um sold his first novel uh
had won been nominated for a bunch of
hugo nebula awards really a brilliant
rising star
i think and like three months after he
won the best new writer
he died of a massive heart attack while
at his typewriter
and it occurred to me when that happened
gosh tom was only 42 years old he was 10
years older than me but
i'm thinking i got all the time in the
world to write these billion books that
i want to write maybe i don't
so maybe it's time to roll the dice and
and quit teaching
walk away from the security you know i
can always go back to it if i fail
if my books don't sell if i can't pay my
bills i can always go back to it but
let's take the chance let's roll the
dice and see where it
it led and i have never regretted that
decision
i don't think any of us regret that
decision george